we're actually going to circle back to
friday night where toronto's mateo roach
had her jeopardy run come to an end my
goodness
and while she went into the final
jeopardy with eight thousand dollars
difference she answered the question
incorrectly while her competitor
danielle moore
guessed correctly and beat out matea
by one
one dollar just one dollar
in a new interview matteo reflected on
her jeopardy journey and her cool cash
winnings that total over half a million
dollars amazing run for her take a look
i can't help but think back to your
first victory when you earned you know
thirty thousand dollars and you said my
student loan is gone now over five
hundred thousand dollars later
wow oh my god i'm like i'm trying not to
cry because like my student loan being
paid off was like the biggest possible
thing that i could have dreamed of when
i came down here and so to have that
happen in the first game was just the
most incredible feeling and i felt like
everything else after that was just
going to be basically playing for fun
and you know play every game like it's
your last and that's what i tried to do
i really tried to fight till the end and
i can't even fathom like this amount of
money i don't know what it is in
canadian dollars but this is like it's
unbelievable can we do that math right
now what is it in canadian dollars kate
i'm i mean i wasn't ryan our director
get out your math
what is that on canadian dollars
calculate that for us